thanks so much Neal and all you guys for
coming out so just to set the floor for
me get a sense of where everyone
coming from how many of you have heard
of data skeptic I didn't say if you
asked if you liked it just who's heard
of it all right cool so a few hands down
to give you a quick synopsis Oh that'd
get cut out on the live show or on the
edited show we're a weekly podcast you
can find us on iTunes stitcher all those
sorts of places or at data skeptic calm
but don't go til January it's a sites
messed up and we do topics in and around
data science so machine learning stats
AI that kind of thing we tend to take on
themes or seasons or whatever you want
to call it so last year we did about six
months on artificial intelligence
followed by six months on fake news and
this year I got really lucky we switched
to the topic of natural language
processing in January and this has been
an absolutely historic time for that
field so I got lucky with that and come
this upcoming January we're gonna talk
all about model interpret ability and
this a little preview not widely known
so mainly we're an interview show and
I'm gonna bring up two guests in a
little bit but I got how many people
were here yesterday for the sorta more
hands-on workshop day all right I really
good I'm glad so many people were I was
a little jealous of how much hands-on
stuff was going on and walking around I
saw so many laptops open not to Outlook
but to sublime or atom or vs code and I
was like well okay we should really do
something legit here to kick off the
show especially since I have a visual
by the way listeners is what I look like
so under the topic of service another
show hands who has never heard of or
does not know what serverless is don't
be shy all right we got a couple
serverless is a kind of self-explanatory
it's a software that need not have a
server the best example or the canonical
one is lambda functions and I think AWS
was the first people to put that out
basic idea of a lambda function and I'll
show you something a little intro here
it's where you give your code to a
service provider in that case AWS but
all the clouds have them and they will
run that code for you under certain
circumstances so a classic example is
you upload a image to your s3 bucket or
your Azure blob store or whatever the
case maybe and you'd like to have a
thumbnail of that you don't need to bog
your webserver down with that or even
worry about having a good pool of
computers because what if you get bursty
traffic the offering of serverless is
hey every time an image shows up we'll
just run this function and charge you a
very tiny bit of money for each run and
you'll get your magical little thumbnail
showing up all the time scaling a lot of
the problems that data people don't like
to work on get pushed off to the cloud
provider server list has come a long way
and I was kind of lucky to attach my
horse to it early on for some of our
client projects and especially our
internal work so the demo I want to put
together right now is really gonna be a
little bit live coding mainly meant to
emphasize how easy this has become and
I'll spare you the how it was uphill
both ways when I got going let's see
let's pop into a good directory here
there's an application I'm going to show
you guys called chalice or I guess is a
framework it's from AWS I think it might
be open source there are lots of
projects like this Zappa is another
Python one we use Claudia jeaious and
node and if you go Google server list
framework there's probably been two
released today so in the case of chalice
you do chalice I think new project bla
bla bla and that has created a directory
for you and inside our two files a
requirements file that I take for
granted everyone here knows about and a
pretty simple app file and then two
really magic commands the first one
shall is local is going to run that on a
little local web server and for all the
flask people this is very flask inspired
so when we pull that up
we get the hello world alright that's on
my local Drive great also nice for
active reloads so let's open that up and
just change that hello
and it's rebuild and we get our
exclamation points
okay local wonderful now my favorite
part chalice deploy for the built in CI
CD it's going to create and I am role
for you and do all the stuff that is
kind of perplexing when you start with
the cloud and really just tries to wrap
things up in a nice way and make it kind
of easy for people who are who are
already comfortable with something like
flask so here are deployment is done
I've been given an end point by the way
this is a public endpoint so you guys
can hit this if you need to know how
hello the world is today but actually as
I was working on this I thought you know
what why don't we try and make it
something a little bit more practical
let's see how far I can get kind of
quickly and I did the cooking show thing
where I pre baked it so I don't have any
of those typical issues one might have
let's now look at this is a repository
if anyone wants to look along its data
- skeptic on github and it's serverless
- demo - PI data 2019 you'll notice I've
done a whole bunch of branches here and
made myself some fake PRS these will
help kind of walk you through the steps
if I go a little bit too fast cuz I do
want to get to our panel discussion but
let's go through it a bit manually then
let's see what branch I'm on step one
and let's open that over here and see
what we've got
that's a preview for later so an app I
didn't do too much I thought you know
why don't we have some sort of a live
shoutouts board so I created three end
points one we'll just return this
dictionary of whatever a shout out is a
get request where you could get a single
one in a post request where you can push
something to it so let's uh
Challis local that and I believe in the
readme I gave some little examples here
so let's post this one I get back the
response acknowledgement true and just
to decompose this for you a little bit
let's go back to app this is a nice way
to do dynamic parameters so I said slash
out slash whatever in this case I put my
name that will just take whatever the
body is I sent it if it's Jason it'll
JSON Fi it if it's a string is just
gonna strip it put it in that dictionary
so that now if we go back to our when I
just not go in that secret mode and stay
over here it's just local now we listen
to okay Kyle listen to data skeptic
great let's see what I didn't step to
now notice I did this hacky way of
putting an object in memory if this were
a flask app that probably would have
been fine because it's gonna stay
resident memory for as long as the
server's up although of course there's
no persistence here but what about
servers that go down that's something
you lose when it comes to server lists
you get no commitment about the
container that it's going to run in and
how fresh that will be you can counter
things like the cold start problem that
we'll get into a bit later but for the
moment I saw okay step three wasn't good
enough or a step two there let's check
out step three and what's changed so oh
get check out step two arjan stuff to
get check out step 3 what have I changed
hmmm let me get check out step 4
there we go here I'm introducing to
let's go to my PRS that'll tell the
story a little cleaner so the first
thing I did here is open these in order
putting that readme so you guys would
know how to access the links and just
split it out to the shoutouts idea
okay fun we can post a little thing on
the board next I need to get that
deployed of course to make it a real end
point so I set up the deploy and then
switched over my readme so you can see
this actual live URL I'll make it a
little bigger in a bit in case anybody
does want to hit it because you'll see
where I'm going next I said okay this is
cool but I need to save that because as
I found out when I ran it that object
that little shout outs dictionary is
going to go away between lambda runs
because of course they're very ephemeral
that's fine I'll go ahead and latch on
to DynamoDB a popular key value store
you can get in the AWS ecosystem and
there's similar stuff and every cloud so
I need to create those things I use my
favorite tool terraform to set that up
so do you guys don't know terraform that
should be the thing you learn tonight
because it's super easy and one of the
basically a modern miracle you describe
what you want in this case I want this
table called shout outs I want to pay
per request have a time to live and it's
just going to be indexed done name so I
terraform applied that again we're gonna
do the baking show skip forward and then
i answ my methods so that instead of
using that object i was holding in
memory I'm just doing this case a table
scan very poor practice but good enough
for our demo get an item and most
importantly post that item is now to do
a put item with it here's my terraform
file we looked at and as my last step I
said well you know what we have this
goofy little gimmick can we take this a
step further and make it into our
question and answering tool for when we
hit the end of the session today will
open up for questions so I if you skip
ahead all the way to the last step and
let me check that one out go to here and
double check now let me show you what
the last step includes instead of just
returning the date I get back from
DynamoDB I throw it into Python or into
pandas kind of unnecessary but I love
the pandas to html4
a quick way to spit this out and then
I'm using one of the chalice
functionalities to tell it that hTML is
coming back so let's go ahead and deploy
this I think it's deployed but I've been
messing around a lot so let's make sure
there we are
and I could really use some testers if
anybody's got a curl handy Oh No
internal server error what could be
wrong I really want to have our Q&A
thing maybe I'll play with that in a
minute while we were chatting so I want
to invite up to this stage my two guests
first and foremost if you were here
earlier and saw the other great server
list talk that was a good bootstrap
opportunity to get involved in server
lists if you haven't seen it the videos
are coming online
Rochelle Brenner please come to the
stage and we've got a mic floating
around that'll come to you so I'll let
you introduce yourself when that shows
up secondly last but no least my
colleague Alex Reeves please come on up
both people very experienced hands on
with some serverless stuff so I thought
given that I'm traditionally an
interview show we could get into some
really good things around this and talk
about use cases and maybe some war
stories and that kind of thing so do we
have that second mic or I'll pass this
for now while we why don't we go past
you guys wait give a quick intro to who
you are and how you got up on stage here
hey everybody I'm Alex been working with
Kyle at data skeptic for about a year
now and I came out of a ph.d program at
UCLA in neuroscience and knew that I
wanted to get into data science but I
wasn't sure what exactly it was gonna
look like so applying for a lot of gigs
did a few short stints and then Kyle put
an advertisement up on his on his show I
was listening to a lot of data science
podcast at the time to like you know get
myself in like knowledgeable about the
field and things worked out and I've had
a great time working with him in the
past year and so we've done some service
projects and
I'm excited to you know share any kind
of takeaways that I've had using
servlets with like machine learning
stuff like that
hi I'm Michele I'm actually a software
engineer for the past nine years I have
I think the literal opposite education
of you because I went to art school and
I got involved in service basically the
last year so I could do my own
infrastructure and don't have to worry
about pulling and all the resources and
kind of finished projects instead of
always just doing the backend and not
getting it up in the club cool well
let's do a softball to get going and
just say what is it that excites you
guys the most about serverless I can
start and kind of expand on that it it's
it's easier than regular infrastructure
so for for me coming from an engineering
background and not a DevOps or
infrastructure background I found that
an easier path to get into to build my
own projects and I love the idea of only
paying for what you use I might talk I
called it the spirit airline of what I
wanted to do for me
serverless has also made it easy to
collaborate I was able to pretty quickly
hook into a chatbot project that we've
been working on quite a bit this year so
like I I came in with not a ton of
experience in production izing machine
learning pipelines I don't know a ton
about how servers even work to be honest
beyond you know what I have to write out
in the configuration files but because
of you know awesome advances like
terraform and all the components the
serverless components that aw well you
know I mostly use AWS I'll be talking to
my experience with AWS mostly here but
all the cool service components that 80
of us has has made it really easy for me
to you know build out like batch jobs
that build models and we can use those
models to serve inferences for our chat
BOTS
and I was able to do that you know in a
couple of months of you know ramped up
time
and and now it's much easier to add new
features to a project so it's been great
yeah for me it's I'm actually gonna
since this part of the demo failed looks
like I'm not able to install pandas for
some reason package download err a weird
one
there's probably pandas people here who
could help but instead I will jump into
showing you guys some behind-the-scenes
code this is an application we use and
I'll blow this up to actually publish
the podcast and do a number of other
things this is again with the Challis
framework and here you can see why I
have fallen in love with it I'm writing
stuff that looks awesome Lille Ike's
flask code but I get these decorators to
come along with it on s3 event so
anytime an s3 object is created this
function will run on a schedule this
function will run on an SMS message this
one will run and on anything put into an
sqs queue this will run so we're able to
build up this pretty cool pipeline we go
into our publishing tools we have a
github webhook that calls this API the
answering services job is just to write
out the contents of that web hook to s3
then that s3 thing kicks off we go into
this parse new file which runs through a
bunch of applications and basically says
do you know how to handle this do you
know how to handle this do you know how
to handle this until we get to our
publishing tool that says oh you're a
github webhook
yeah use this parser that parsha goes
and downloads the data stores it and in
s3
again kicks this off and says is it a
markdown file is it a Jupiter notebook
is it an R markdown file if so here's
how you parse those and convert them
into HTML which again you save if it's
an HTML file then we push it out to a
different s3 bucket which is the live
static web site so that's just the show
notes part of it we have a whole
pipeline set up in a similar service
fashion where when we upload the mp3 it
kicks off a normalization of the audio
kicks off transcription and all these
kind of great services that I don't know
how we would have built it with a small
team just even a few years ago without
server lists so I think that's really
where my love of it comes from do you
guys have a favorite use case either
when you've personally been involved
with or one that
aware of I think there's two really
great use cases one is when a service is
gonna have to run that often so why have
a server up 24 hours a day when it's
gonna run once a day so it runs you know
you pay for the two seconds and then
you're done and then the other use case
is when you have a million requests when
you have a huge message queue of data
you have to process in my case what I
was working on was hitting a third party
API I don't want to make sure it wasn't
hurting you know bring down my web
client as many people as make the
request as slow as the third party is I
don't want to worry about it so every
time there was a message it would spin
up a new service function as to whether
I had to or a million it could handle it
so those kind of ends and then if you
have just like a normal path of not very
high traffic that's where you should
just have like a regular easy to server
up yeah I think I also have enjoyed kind
of the batch job part of it the most is
spin up a Big Easy to instance for
example and then you know do a heavy
workload and then just expect it to be
spun down on its own after it's done
maybe you should go into what batches I
bet not everyone here knows about that
service maybe maybe they don't so one of
the great things right so AWS is kind of
maybe Godfather of server lists and and
they the poster child their server lists
services like lambda which is functions
as a service right you write a function
and then it manages running that
function for you but some of the
limitations of lambda are that it's got
you know low you can only you have
limited execution time running a lambda
and then you have limited compute
resources when running a lambda - that's
I don't know the details of why they
have it set up that way that's just how
Amazon has decided to manage their
lambda functions but they do have
another service called an Amazon batch
and with that you have
I'm not even sure if there is an
execution runtime limit and you have
access to much much larger compute
resources so you can like the use case
that I'm talking about here building
machine learning models with AWS batch I
mean they handle you know allocating all
those compute resources for you so that
you have a big machine that could load
like a large language model like Bert it
was the use case that we had and then do
do all kinds of like retrieving
embeddings from birds and then using
those embeddings to build a model off of
and they also handle like the
orchestration of it so if you want
multiple jobs happening where yes you
want to build one model one way but you
give some other parameters to build the
model a different way for another job
you know they can scale that way way up
and and you're still able to allocate
like large resource jobs or large large
computer resources for these heavy
workloads and so it's been a little bit
of a learning curve at first figuring
out you know how it is you know there's
there's a queue that that you that ADA
base manages to get like all the jobs
lined up for you to say ok now it's this
job's turn to run on this compute
environment and so it takes a little bit
of time getting used to you but once you
have that it's great pretty much anytime
you're running a cron job you could just
turn that into an ad this batch job and
so there's lots of use cases for it
sorry I sent you on a tangent with my
sub question I was asking about favorite
use cases
you gave us some so let me know if I
have one I guess I'm gonna have to pick
our publishing system because how cool
is it that the whole podcast runs
serverless especially the audio pipeline
which we're just kind of finishing up
these last couple weeks you Alex you
touched on some of the limitations of
serverless maybe we could spin off of
that are there situations in which you
guys would
against adoption of serverless any types
of projects it's not a good fit or maybe
not the ideal tool I mean there is some
overhead associated with setting up a
service project so I think a one-off
analysis you know you don't want to do
server lists and like Michelle was
saying you made a good point about how
like if the loads the demand loads are
predictable and consistent and maybe you
don't need the server list where that's
exactly the resume is it's like it's
best for like the things you need to run
not that often and the things you that
need to run a huge scale otherwise it's
actually just cheaper to have a regular
server up this fielding requests because
there is when they under mention there's
like we all like to talk about how it's
like oh it's just writing the function
but like there's such a huge learning
curve for this so that's why I said on
my talk like 400 times it's you'll get
through it and once you build it
updating it is so much easier and once
you have that infrastructure in place
and once you kind of understand all the
moving parts I like it because it's
someone else has done the work for you
and a lot of different ways you can
basically find an Amazon service to do
anything and if you can't find it you
can complain and they'll probably write
it yeah I am there are limits to service
that are I think when you get extremely
technical so in a way they're almost
uninformative because if you don't worry
about latency and network lag and cold
starts of docker containers then you're
probably developing something that isn't
you know a medical application isn't
mission-critical
and whether or not you those are even
relevant issues for you is questionable
I feel like you kind of have to know
about the problems with server lists to
even bump into them but the best example
I can think of there's an interview on
software engineering daily where Jeff's
talking to somebody from like a sporting
video company I figured what it is but
the problem they have is that sporting
events tend to be like live focused so
their traffic all shows up at exactly
the same time and that is a really bad
use case for lambda because
concurrency limitations if you have your
own pool of servers I mean hopefully the
pool is big enough but you kind of
manage it and it's hot and ready all the
time the cloud providers have the sort
of no particular guarantees I suppose
are some SLA somewhere but there's no
real guarantee that your code won't have
a little lag every so often in fact if
your code doesn't run often they may
spin down the hot container they have
behind the scenes to run it and put it
like in some sort of cold storage and
the next time it's required has to
defrost before it's ready I have
experienced that but it's the kind of
thing like where all right you got to
talk to our chat bot and it lags for
like three seconds on the first message
you're probably gonna blame your cell
phone provider not us and if it were a
big issue I guess I'd ping it constantly
and that probably suit us but that like
bursts of concurrency is an issue but
also probably the kind that the AWS
people would want to help you with
because it improves their product which
actually brings me to a good point I
have seen massive improvements in the
tooling and Technology around serverless
in just the last year what about you
guys there's new things that come out
all the time and I can tell us new
because I can't figure out how to use it
basically like a new thing that came out
was lambda layers which is a way to
reuse your codes you're not you know
always putting new code in your lambdas
and I still haven't gotten it to work
but it'll get there and one thing that
actually came out of reinvent this week
is at that cold boot problem they have a
solution for it so yeah there we have it
so that's exactly yeah and with the cold
start problem you see that with the AWS
batch service - but I think it has to do
with just having to assemble all those
compute resources and they call it batch
for a reason you know it's like no they
they want you they it's intended to be a
batch job kind of process yeah if I'm
gonna train a model for an hour I can
wait 30 seconds to spin up yeah so
besides the kind of vanilla use cases
you know the image thumbnailing I'd
mentioned may be you know moving around
files or something what are some of the
more novel use cases you think might
surprise people or
you're thinking about applying service I
was so I've been really impressed with
some of the stuff coming out of Google
magenta just for some personal projects
so I feel that in those so people know
what that is so so I'm I'm into music I
I'm not a musician but it's definitely a
big hobby of mine and magenta is this
project at Google that's main focus is
to look at the intersection between AI
and art and see you know what can a I
are for artists a lot of the projects
end up revolving around music there's
some other stuff about graphic design
and drawing that I haven't looked into
as much but it seems really cool and
with magentas music stuff in particular
there's this model that they've got for
transcribing piano music into MIDI I
don't know if you guys know MIDI is but
it's you know like a file format for
representing musical notes and so what I
think is so awesome about that is that
it can take years and years of of
rigorous study to be able to transcribe
piano music into music notes but this
model that they've got on sets and
frames I think has a really great
accuracy for turning music into piano
music into MIDI so it's piano specific
they trained this model basically on
this data set of piano competitions so
they've got like gigabytes and gigabytes
of audio data that correspond perfectly
with a MIDI file that represents the
performance of that audio file and so
they use that to train the model to be
able to translate audio into MIDI and so
I thought that was so cool because the
accurate accuracy is great
I turned that into a basically Python
scripts and docker file so I don't know
how much familiarity people have with
docker but it's basically a way to like
reproducibly run compute jobs so like in
my case it's like you know running this
Python script that loads a machine
learning model that to translate audio
into MIDI and I put that into AWS batch
job basically so I have the doc I have
the docker image running in a dispatch
and I can send it a audio file and then
later in s3 it deposits a MIDI file for
me and it'd be fun to one day kind of
open that up to other people so that
they can take advantage of this really
cool machine learning model to turn like
audio into MIDI neat yeah so security
and compliance I don't know if anyone
has ever had to work on something that
required compliance like PCI which is
credit card compliance or in healthcare
where you have to be very careful how
you store data and who has access of
data and how you can deploy code and how
you can access that database by
segregating the code that requires
compliance
it makes compliance so much easier so if
I just create one micro service that all
it does is the credit card processing
that's the only service micro service
that I have to have to be compliant and
no one can touch another part of that is
using Amazon's encryption it's very easy
so anyone who is storing credit card
numbers and plain text you're just like
the laziest person on earth because it's
literally like that and crypt dot
decrypt because it's all in the service
already so all the keys are stored
together and you want to account and you
don't worry about moving all those parts
around so it makes that set much easier
and then you could be all those services
that don't touch that secure data or
that secure code you can just go wild on
and all your developers can deploy
because you're not
worried about losing someone's data yeah
there's a lot of like old man things I
bump into I called that when I'm like
back in my date kind of stuff
so much about like how do developers get
their own environment does it run the
same on my machine these are like
antique problems at this point with
modern frameworks and stuff I think I
like your idea of security and
compliance there's to me in my mind two
layers of server list sort of like the
the children and the adults almost like
the basic stuff being that make a
thumbnail of an image really useful
quick simple things and then there's
like serverless application development
which is like orchestrating micro
services together which is partially why
I like this chalice example that I have
all these you know this is a bunch of
lambda functions when it gets deployed
but I wrote it as if it were a
traditional software application but
more than that I'm gonna kind of
philosophize for a moment and share some
thoughts I've had about this the way I
designed now when we do server this
really centralizes around a queuing
mechanism so you'll notice we're
listening for queue events here and we
do something called process work which
takes a very generic event and is a
short bit of code why well because I
want to write really really tight unit
tests against this process event
function so that I'm not worried about
like oh I deployed it and some weird
thing happened or the format's different
I want to have the most minor of a
difference between the way lambdas gonna
run it and the way I run it locally but
also if I'm just putting everything on
this queue or better yet an s like an
SNS topic or a Kinesis stream then you
can always have lambda functions
attached to that they do so really
easily and anybody can latch on to that
so even though I've never had this
happen yet I have this promise I make a
lot of clients it's like oh we'll just
put stuff on here and when you're
building wants to look at it they can
just listen to events and aggregate them
and if some fraud detection engineers
come around who are really really smart
at fraud if you have a good event stream
they don't need to learn your custom
schema they can just go sniff those
events and grab a chunk of the data and
start training models even in real time
with some of the tools that are coming
out so I think event-driven programming
is
almost hand-in-hand for server list with
me how do you guys feel about it yeah I
do both I have M point base and then I
use it a lot for cron tasks because it's
such a great like something I need to
run once a week I just set up an event
bridge task and it just runs the lambda
and then I don't have to worry about it
which is nice cuz just running that
little bit of code and I'll have to put
her on a server it'll just be done when
it's done for me I'm still kind of
getting used to the whole event-driven
programming paradigm to be perfectly
frank but it's it's interesting what
what I have trouble getting used to is
like it's basically all comes down to
sending messages so yeah it's I guess I
get the gist of it but I don't have I
don't have a firm grasp on how the whole
philosophy works so I think it's because
you came straight to work for us at
academia if you'd been in a big company
you'd know this policy called not my job
which is the best way I like to think
about event-driven it's like you see an
event you say someone else should do
this to it and it's just this kind of
chain of transformations and they're
auditable and all that kind of stuff one
of the thing that comes up a lot and if
thank you and cueing is like the slow
queue and the fast queue and you always
want to separate all those tasks right
you need separate queues for your emails
then your image processing or your you
know if you're processing large amounts
it just data on the backend or videos
like that you can put that in a slow
queue and by having this server less you
can break them all up so people have
been stretching the definition of what
server this means almost at the point
where sometimes I'm like come on really
that's ok yeah do you guys have any
services that have stuck out in your
mind or are you waiting for a server
list service to appear I'm thinking of
things like Athena
I think stage maker claims to be service
not sure what else but batch is also a
good example like I was running a
container service how do you guys feel
about the sort of abuse of this word
I would say I'm not waiting as much for
technology as much as I'm waiting for
tutorials like there's so many use cases
for it and I'm often finding that I will
get like here's all the flags you can
use but no explanation of how to
actually use it and I just want all
those use cases because I think there's
just so much creativity that we haven't
tapped into or document it or because
maybe people are using it in these cool
ways and I just can't figure it out and
I feel like using I mean use terraform I
use cloud formation they're basically
the same thing yeah and they're just
maddening because you'll find different
syntax in cloud formation versus the
console versus the command line and I
want that more than I want new features
just like fix what you have yeah that's
fair let's see so along those lines we
have shown Alex and I are AWS bias not
because we're shields but because we
just sort of that's what we work on for
the most part I was really glad Michelle
and your talk to hear how agnostic you
were and some of the trials and
tribulations of being serverless on the
big three platforms can you share maybe
some summary of your talk that people
can watch later or just some lessons
from the field about what was easiest
and most difficult so Amazon obviously
has most of the market share they have
most of the products so it's kind of
easier to step in to accept they're also
locked into this legacy design which
Microsoft and Google kind of took that
design I was like oh let's make it
easier and better so they've been able
to learn some lessons which is nice but
since so many less people use it you'll
find less documentation there's a little
less support but Google is the only
company that responded to a support
ticket so I always like to say that and
shame Microsoft and Amazon for not
responding to me for weeks I would love
that to become its own project I think
we should form like a union of
developers and shame the clouds that
don't yeah I've actually given this talk
and I didn't realize that these
developers were in the room and I've got
taken back and be like oh it's worse
than you think like
it's more complicated like you miss some
parts that were like more confusing then
you ran into and we're just it's hard to
keep up with the pace of development and
make that documentation better and I
wish they would just slow down and like
my dream feature is to have in the
console a button that you can just click
and it'll give you the the command line
and the CloudFormation version of what
you just did because I feel like I spent
so much time trying to figure out what
that is yeah can you patent that some
kind of way are we still doing patents I
I pitched it like everyone in the
company and I'm just like just be
postman like postman doesn't one can't
you yeah it's a good model for sure I
personally feel it's a bit like the
journey we were on with Big Data you
know beginning kind of with breakthrough
technologies like a dupe which were
wonderful and that they worked but
terrible and that you had to use them
and evolved into stuff like spark and
even like spark sequel I mean now you
don't have to know anything about
distributed computing to just write
sequel queries and you can do big data
stuff I think we're getting there with
serverless where are we on the journey
how long before people who you know
don't want to bang their heads against
the wall every day are comfortable
saying these are mature toolings for me
it's about none legacy people being able
to use it right so I would always see
this documentation that would be like
they would use a as an example to
explain b-but I don't know what a is so
none of this helps me because they
assumed I already had that domain
knowledge of a system administrator or
someone who built infrastructure so I
think it's when it starts to become so
easy that anyone can just spin up their
own tools like the tools are so powerful
I just want to tell people who aren't
even engineers who want to start
businesses like I want you to be able to
use this if only the documentation was a
little better then you could get it so I
feel like once the companies realize
they if they make you know visual
versions of what they're doing and make
it actually production ready then it'll
just explode and anyone will be able to
you very quickly bring their apps to
life which is like my dream anyone who's
you know has barely written any code to
just dream big very cool I think we all
have our own war stories about the
simple tasks that took three days you
know we see these demos like the one
I've failed to complete here where it's
like hey in ten minutes you have stuff
up and indeed we did get the hello world
up we just couldn't get my Dynamo
installed I think probably because of a
Wi-Fi issue but nonetheless I'm sure
you've had painful experiences are
comfortable sharing any and some lessons
learned I've got more than my fair share
if you guys do it I've definitely had my
share of difficult experiences with
terraform there's a learning curve
because a lot of times for me you know
it's just a big configuration file
basically is what terraform is we're
cloud formation I guess in that case and
[Music]
understanding what these configuration
settings mean can be a bit overwhelming
at first especially if there's a lot of
ink interconnected parts and my kind of
tip for dealing with that overwhelming
amount of infrastructure is to mess
around with with the UI or the console a
bit and any tutorials that they have
because for me it makes a huge
difference to kind of picture what I'm
doing when I'm writing out these
configurations and and saying okay I
want a ec2 instance of this size and I
want yeah I want the there to be an
execution time limit of this amount for
the lambda function and so just getting
at getting a sense for like a big
picture of what the what the whole what
each component can do and what and how
it interconnects with other components
in the ecosystem was was really tough
using just a configuration file I'm
gonna build on that talk about
permissions
they're the worst I think it's a lot of
my walls I ran into was just not
understanding the design and what the
intention was and once I kind of wrap my
mind around that I got it so every
service you use so lambda is the
function and then dynamodb is a database
they both need permission to talk to
each other and in real life it doesn't
make any sense right like it's like
we're co-workers and I have to like give
him a passcode to chat with him like
that doesn't make any sense we we sit
right next to each other but once you
realize that it's just one of those
barriers where it's like okay I need to
make sure every service has the
permission it needs and just doing
things one at a time I think is really
helpful like don't try to plan your
entire service like just get the
database and deploy it and see if it
deploys and then add on the lambda on
top of it and then add on the encryption
and just once I got into that rhythm of
one at a time because you might have to
deploy it 20 times to get that database
to work to get that syntax exactly
correct but when you have like seven
things you'll you'll never figure it out
because the error messages can be up too
so if you've only changed one thing you
know like well at least I've limited the
area that I have messed up yeah I think
for me what I bumped into a lot of
problems where things would you know
they works on my computer kind of
situation which is exacerbated by the
fact that the cloud is not your local
computer especially when it comes to
permissions so we can write a fun little
line like let's scroll up in here import
Bato three and then where am i using
some bottle three do you guys do boto or
Bato what's the consensus here hands up
for Bato oh man okay I don't guess we'll
do boto today all right hands up for
boat oh geez all right moto three that
client as you guys know this is grabbing
from my dot AWS slash credentials at
least on Mac and Linux works great
locally because I have a fairly generous
I am key in my development thing when
you deploy this you are going to get the
role of the lambda that's assigned which
is totally configurable
but a little bit obtuse chalice tries to
take care of that for you does is
generally a good job but there's one
weird trick and this is a trick that all
of you will owe me about eight hours of
your time after I teach you this chalice
begins by declaring a chalice app like
this and if you want this to kind of
realize that you're going to use AWS
services that you'd like it to provision
a role for then you have to explicitly
call them afterwards so if up here I had
said something like you know s3 client
is boto three dots client s3 you would
not get the s3 permissions which is sort
of not intuitive at all but moving it
down here suddenly something with the
compiler I don't know I didn't look
under the hood but you get that to work
then it's because the app can see it and
it will provision that for you but
figuring that out on your own is just
not elegant today so one of those things
where I think it'll become elegant you
know things are getting better when we
started there was no Auto provisioning
of the role so at least we have that
maybe it could just provision itself a
little better but all things in time I
suppose I just have one fun story you
can make things you can't delete which I
realize like I'm you kms keys you can
provision them and then realize that you
didn't give yourself permission to edit
them and then you can't delete them like
you literally have to give route
permission to edit them and I was just
like a team this cost a dollar a month I
don't know how to delete it I guess it's
there forever I don't know but like
those are just like the fun things that
happen we don't realize that nothing is
automatic like you don't automatically
get permission to do that yeah yeah
although I have to say with as much as
we've kind of complained I have seen a
generally monotonically increasing
improvement and the tooling and stuff I
can't think of a big step back that I
was mad about which is a typical I
usually am mad about something in a new
version so that might be a good sign are
you guys building anything interesting
at the moment in a service fashion
I know you are well let's see I can talk
about ID images if you want ID images
okay yeah so with that it's been an
interesting project where we're
leveraging some of the you know
event-driven programming that that
you're doing that we're doing with with
chalice and what we've got going on is
like a system where we want to turn
images of nutritional labels so like
what you would see on the back on the
side of a cereal box and you know
determine whether those labels are in
compliance with FDA regulations so
there's a lot of regulations it's a it's
a big long document with different
things to consider about like font types
relative font sizes and things of that
nature and we want to automate as much
of that as possible so we're using
Amazon text tract don't know if you guys
have heard of this service to you know
in a server list way I collect extracted
text from all these nutritional labels
and you know check features about
relative font sizes what what kind of
wording is used in order to determine
whether nutrition labels are in
compliance and you know without without
extract without I mean OCR is is that's
what extract does no duty OCR and it's
an essential technology and then making
it kind of a managed service by AWS
really kind of makes it easy to do at
scale so that's been that's been a fun
project yeah so I touched a little bit
of how I use it in production a lot
doing third party API is and compliance
but you could also use it for very silly
things so until the story of what
happened this Thanksgiving my sister
came to visit me and we both realized
that our parents were
to contact us on Thanksgiving and send
us nothing we're like well not even a
text messages from them so instead I
decided to make a parental approval but
with Twilio and server lists that will
send me aspirational messages like I'm
actually proud of you please I
remembered your birthday please tell me
about your life and you can pretend this
from your parents and just like the nice
thing about it's a nice part of services
it's once you get the hang of it you can
make templates and it's easy to spin up
nonsense projects for yourself and make
fun of my parents yeah
well you hit on an interesting point as
well I mean I can't thinking about my
life I have a graveyard of like
interesting little projects that worked
and then some servers no longer up or
whatever server this is kind of forever
and you pay basically zero so if you
have some little project if it gets
popular you'll be paying for it but
that's kind of a good problem to have
right so it's a neat way that I think as
developers will have more permanence of
the things we built so maybe we need to
build them better really represent who
we are and what we're trying to do with
their careers and whatnot
we haven't touched at all really on
Python of course serverless is available
on almost every language and let's just
say every language because that's where
things are headed but python as far as I
understand remains the most popular
deployment why do you guys suppose that
is Python is easy compared to other
languages it's also for people who are
planning to create quick things I think
pythons like a go-to language because
you can script in it if you're creating
more enterprise projects you're you know
you're using something like net you're
less likely to be able to move to the
new technology so I think that's why I
think Python is up there and why I like
using it yeah I mean this I don't have a
strong opinion about this about this but
it seems like python is go-to language
one of the go-to languages for like IT
and server administration stuff so it
seems like you want to be able to
support that kind of language when it
comes to
building server lists applications
service infrastructures yeah for me it's
the complaints I used to have about
Python by the way most of which kind of
got resolved with Python 3 I'm glad that
you have optional typing and things like
that now even though it's fake typing
it's there and it basically does what I
want it to all those like criticisms of
this will be hard to manage if it gets
to a million lines of code because there
isn't hard compile time checking the way
you get in typescript or Java those
problems kind of don't matter in the
server this world because your code is
supposed to do a simple thing and be
done and if anything you're just gonna
chain a bunch of simple things together
which also gets back to kind of
event-driven what I think is a healthy
coding style when we pull up another
code example this is mine so I can show
it in the podcast for example a blog
update request that's the work in
progress let's see yes like we have just
an add a blog function all I need is a
title an abstract a year and the slug
which is what we call the sort of root
file that came over from github which we
use as a CMS and this is one line of
code that just has to get triggered by
the function and if I make some change
and I want to introduce some new
property or something it's not a big
deal that some object is not expected
and I forgot something plus I can unit
test the heck out of this and just this
function and even though Python doesn't
necessarily have its claim to fame isn't
necessarily its elegant unit testing it
does the job for me for sure and just
the ability to write very declarative
simple short code and also import really
powerful libraries is I think why it's
kind of the leader at least why I choose
it for most things have you guys seen
any oh actually I want to ask about
legacy systems there are sometimes
motivations to maintain a legacy system
and other times time to reinvent do you
have any thoughts or best practices on
how to answer a question like that if
software organization is dealing with
some rather monolithic system that does
happen to run how do they know if a
server list migration would be right for
them I've actually worked on this type
of project so just
peel off something and try it that's
basically what we did we're just like
okay let's try one thing that we do in
our giant mono repo as a small thing you
do that or oh I this new feature I don't
want to touch this monster let's make it
completely separate as its own thing and
see if it interacts well and you can
slowly change it or you know or you
could just leave it alone and just add
all new things as micro-services but
when you know it's everyone knows the
problem of legacy systems right the more
people who work on it over time the
harder it is gonna get to work with so
put that's the whole push to those micro
services where you're less likely to
have to developers working on the same
file or all the developers leaving and
no one knowing how to use it
these two micro services it's a very
planned execution so I think you can
definitely do it and there's many ways
to do it and you might as well try it
and if it doesn't work then you leave
the way it is yeah yeah I think you hit
on a key point it's if you're going to
adapt to micro service architecture
which if you're not you kind of almost
have to justify that anymore
but if you are it lends very nicely to
service and it's just really nice with
the server list you can push a lot of
that burden on to the engineer make them
deploy themselves and yeah you know and
they'll learn something and they'll be
able to handle the whole system and kind
of be more responsible for the whole
pipeline yeah and if I may be so bold I
think it'll become almost a de facto
standard
I imagine engineers working in
businesses around the turn of the
century might have had to worry about
the electrical system staying up I don't
know of any business at least in the
u.s. that worries that the electric is
gonna be on you just take that for
granted and I think some of the services
like these functions will scale
infinitely and all that kind of stuff
can be taken for granted so we're
getting to the end I want to save a few
minutes for questions if there are any I
think if there's extra mics we've got
this one here we can pass and then
everybody on stage can share this one so
I'll run that down so my question is to
Michelle you mentioned earlier in one of
your responses that a good way to try to
build out your entire framework is to
take one thing at a time
and and I agree it is easier to diagnose
problems that way so I guess like as you
came up your own learning curve did you
find yourself as you were layering one
service on at a time or training them
together that you Franken signed
something that was really hard to undo
no because it was kind of I had an idea
of the big picture
I used a chart first right like I draw
everything out I like you lucid chart to
know exactly where I wanted to go and
then I kind of just did one service at a
time until it all worked and the first
time I did it I was like oh this is an
easy template I'll just fill it all in
with my names and it'll work
and it didn't work and that's when I
realized I had to comment most of it out
and try things one at a time
and it's kind of that where I realized
okay this is too complex to do all at
once and I'll just add one service at a
time until you know I checked them off
on my little chart as I added them in I
was wonder if you guys could talk a
little bit more about like your
troubleshooting steps when you have an
application that's working and then
something goes wrong within a server
list environment century is your friend
it was really easy to set up and has
great diagnostic tools they should pay
me because I keep talking about them but
also just you can use all the same
lacking tools that you normally like to
use and just kind of plug it in and see
your trace backs as you're monitoring so
it's much less about the tools and more
about planning on what you want to check
so if your if your service is always
making some nails you can have something
that checks on if there's something some
nails stop happening so it's kind of the
same observability and metrics you do
with any system except you don't need to
do a heartbeat for the server you're
more looking for that the output that
you expected is happening all the time
yeah I've struggled with this so I'll
give some personal advice what worked
for me I've focused very heavily on the
actual like serverless lambda ish parts
like the function that the
top providers gonna actually call to
have as few lines of code as possible
and be some just wrapper function
because the back and forth of deploy
your code test it is kind of a really
bad time sync you end up with these
horrible iteration times where it's like
five minutes for a line of code change
so the more I can unit test and do
things locally and allow just like one
possible point of failure then I can
also try accept that in a you know ideal
way log it however I want but out of box
you will bump into some problems there
logging is not super elegant and mature
the way it is for a lot of other systems
yet so for this server list part I found
that just using the AWS console to debug
lambda functions is actually pretty
speeds up the iterations so that's
that's been useful and then this this is
more ECS ec2 stuff so not exactly server
list but I've always found that it's
like really worth it
especially if you've got like a
development ad bus account where you're
building stuff out in to give all your
ec2 Zess SH keys that way you can you
know SSH into them and see get even more
in visibility into what kind of problems
your service or you know cloud
application is having well we solved all
the problems tonight we can wrap a
minute early I'll certainly stick around
to chat I don't know if you guys are
it's been a long day for all of us I
think
but thanks everybody for coming and yeah
if you're interested in doing service
stuff or just having a conversation
about this it's something we're actively
engaged in eager to engage in and
imagine the same for you Michelle so hit
us up for sure social media and all that
we'll pass it around you could find me
at data skeptic on Twitter and data
skeptic podcast you can find me on
LinkedIn and then you can reach out to
me a email Alex that data skeptic doc
data skeptic comm those would be the two
main ways you can find me on Twitter
at Michelle Linn be and also you should
listen to my podcast called from the
source where I interview working
professionals in tech and we talked
about the good the bad and the boring of
their tech jobs and how to get there
well thank you both so much for coming
out
round of applause for these guys
everybody
[Applause]